[موسيقى]
من العربيه احييكم وهذه نشره المساء
نبداها بابرز العناوين
تزايد التنزيل الدولي بمنع طالبان توظيف
النساء وكبريات ومنظمات الاغاثه تعلق
عملها في افغانستان
غير جديه
[موسيقى]
مسؤولونا صحيون يقرون بملايين اصابات
كرونه بالبلاد وبكين تقرر وقفه نشر بيانات
انتشار الفيروس
[موسيقى]
العواصف الثلجيه القاسيه تواصل ضربه مناطق
امريكيه ضحايا وقطع للكهرباء والتوقف
الرحلات الجويه
[موسيقى]
والبدايه من الجدل الحاصل في افغانستان اذ
اوقفت اربع منظمات اغاثيه اجنبيه عملها في
البلاد وهي من كبرى المنظمات العالميه وهي
انقذ الاطفال والمجلس النرويجي للاجئين
وكير ولجنه الانقاذ الدوليه
مطالبين بمواصله قيام الرجال والنساء
وبشكل متساوي في تقديم المساعدات التي
تنقذ الارواح بينما دعت الخارجيه
الالمانيه الى الحصول على رد فعل موحد
وواضح من المجتمع الدولي ضد افعال طالبان
والانتهاكات بحق النساء كما ندد الصليب
الاحمر بمنع نساء من التعليم والعمل واصفا
قرارات الحركه بالكارسيه
بالطريقه الحاله المسؤوليه على عاتق
الحكومه على عاتق الجماعه التي تدير
الحكومه الان وتعتبر نفسها بانها الحكومه
تشكل الحكومه في افغانستان لكن همم بوجود
المؤسسات الاجنبيه والارافيه الاجنبيه في
افغانستان الحكومه غير قادره على تقديم
هذه الخدمات فبعد مغادره هذه المؤسسات من
افغانستان بكل تاكيد ستتفاقم الازمه بشكل
كبير وسيزيد الضغط على اعتق الحكومه التي
هي اصل عاجزه عن تقديم الخدمات للشعب
الخدمات في مختلفه في القطاعات التي
تغطيها هذه المنظمات الاغاثيه همم البديل
لابد على الحكومه ان تقدم بديلا وهي اصلا
عاجزه عن تقديم البديل لكن همم على اي حال
الضحيه همم ستكون شعبا الافغاني الذي يعيش
اكثر من
79% من هذا الشعب تحت خط الفقر وهي شعب
وهو شعب محتاج جدا لهذه همم
المساعدات الانسانيه والاضافيه
اذا اسوء
السيناريوهات باتت ورده من مع حركه طالبان
التي توصل حملتها لانتهاكيه والقمعيه
لحرمان نساء من التعليم والعمل او حتى
ابسط الحقوق
فعدموا منح الفتيات والنساء حقوقهن سيكون
له عواقب وخيمه على تقديم خدمات الصحه
والتغذيه والتعليم للاطفال وفقه منظمات
دوليه ومراقبين للتطورات الحاصله
انقذوا الاطفال والمجلس النرويجي للاجئين
اكدوا انهم لا يستطيعون الوصول بشكل فعال
الى الاطفال والنساء والرجال الذين هم في
امس الحاجه الى المساعده في افغانستان
بدون موظفاتهم وهنا ادانا الاتحاد
الاوروبي والامم المتحده والولايات
المتحده بشده قراره البان وقالوا بانه
سيؤثر على تقديم المساعدات الانسانيه
وجميع اعمال الاغاثه في المرحله المقبله
اما وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه انتن بلانكن
فقد اكد بان قرار طالبان سيعطل تسليم
المساعدات وقد يكون مدمرا لافغانستان
[موسيقى]
في تقديم المساعدات الانسانيه في
افغانستان سيؤدي الى تعطيل المساعدات
الحيويه والمنقذه لحياه الملايين
[موسيقى]
بدوره هي عبر الامين العام لمنظمه التعاون
الاسلاميه حسينطها عن مخاوف عميقه من قرار
حكومه طالبان تعليق عمل النساء في جميع
المنظمات غير الحكوميه بافغانستان وقالت
المنظمه في بيان ان الامين العام دعا
طالبان لاعاده النظر في القرار مشيرا الى
انه ياتي في اعقاب حظر فرضته الحركه قبل
ايام قليله على التحاق الفتيات بالجامعات
وبين الاحتجاج في الشارع ورفعي الشعارات
تعددت اوجه الاعتراض على قرار طالبان منع
الفتيات من التعليم
افغانيتان وجدنا الغناء وسيله للتعبير في
توجيه رساله رسالتهن
[موسيقى]
رسمه رسمه
رسمته
[موسيقى]
يعني بعد 20 عام للولايات المتحده
الامريكيه داخل افغانستان
100 سنه الى سنه الى الخلفيه ما هي اساليب
الضغط التي تملكها الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه لساني طالبان عن هذه القرارات
حول الادانه الواسيه ليس فقط
هذه القرار الاخير بالنسبه النساء
الافغانستان همم من عمل في المؤسسه غير
الحكوميه وكل هذه القرارات فعلا تؤدي الى
زياده الاصل همم
نعم كما قلت الان كما نرى في الافغانستان
همم هذا ليس همم السبب او ليس مسؤوليه
للشعب الافغانيسه ولكن همم للتعلي معنا
حركه طالبان هي التي تاخذ كل هذه القرارات
همم الولايات المتحده للدينا بعد الاليات
واسمعنا منذ ايام من وزير ملك ان نحن الان
سنباحث من حلفائنا وشركائنا بالنسبه
رساله واضحه للي تعليمات حول هذه القرارات
طيب هذا يعني كيف بفيد الافغانيات والنساء
الافغانيات
واي اجراءات التي
مشاكيل او او تهديات امام الشعب الافغاني
او خاصه النساء والفتيات اكثر
من العقوبات ومن همم اليات اخرى ولكن اهم
شيء الان نحن نريد ركز على الوضع في
ادغانستان واخسرا ووضع بالنسبه النساء
والفتيات والا نريد ناخذ اي اجراءات التي
ستؤدي الى ضرار اكثر
اعمال الاغاثه وجمعيات كبرى يعني انجي اوز
كبيره هل هذا يعاقب طالبان اي يعاقب
الافغانيين
بدون شك هذه القرار من طلبان لمنع النساء
باكماله ليس طالبان ونحن همم الان سنبحث
عن الامكانيه لوصول او ايصال المساعدات
الانسانيه ولكن فقط ليوم سمعنا من بعد
المؤسسات الانجيل المؤسسه غير حكميه انه
ليس من الممكن انهم يستمر في الشغل في
اركان الاسلام
الافغاني من قبل طالبان الان لا تريد
العمل يعني الى اين يؤدي ذلك بالافغانيين
يبدو حتى الان نحن مازال لازم نسمع اكثر
من هذه المؤسسات ولكن هذه المواسسات لا
تاخذ القرار همم اعاقه او او عقوبه ضد
التعليمات لا ليس لديها الامكانيه لتستمر
في الشغل في افغانستان بدون اكثر من نصف
من موظفيها لان نحن نعرف ان النساء بشكل
عام كم سمعنا من وزير ومن زمان
بشكل
العمل الجماعي اكثر واكثر
يعني البعض يلوم الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه وهي تلام بعد 20 عام داخل
افغانستان افغانستان تم تسليم افغانستان
لطالبان هيك بليله
وغادرت الولايات المتحده الامريكيه ونحن
الان بهذه النتيجه
هل تشعر الولايات المتحده الامريكيه باي
من المسؤوليه تجاه ما يحصل داخل افغانستان
هو شاف انه حان وقت ال 20 سنه لانها هذه
الحرب ولازم ندرك انها همم هذه القرار جاء
بعد المفاوضات من الاداره السابقه ترامب
ووزيركم مع بعض ممكن
مباشره وكان التزام من الورقه المتحده من
الاداره السابقه لانسحاب من افغانستان اذن
رئيس بعدين هو كان يتطبق هذه القرار ولكن
في نفس الوقت كنا واضحه جدا من من اليوم
عندما
طبعا كان حركه طالبان اخذت السلطه في
افغانستان كان واضحه جدا ان احنا بجانب او
الى جانب الشعب الافغان ولذلك نحن الان
استمر في تقديم المساعده الانسانيه ونهله
سنستمر في ذلك طيب براي الولايات المتحده
كيف هي افغانستان في ااا في ظل نساء لا
يعني يسمح لهم او لهن بالتعليم او بالعمل
ماذا تتوقعون الا تتوقعون اجيال اكثر
قريبه من الارهاب الا تعودون الى حيث
بداتوا من 20 عام اذا اول اسم ندرك ان كل
هذه القرارها همم من همم النساء من تعليم
من النساء من العمل الجماعي كل هذه
القرارات ستؤدي الى وضع الصور
واقتصاد
والمجتمع المدني اذا كل هذه القراءه لا
تؤدي الى شيئا الى اصل حال في الافغانستان
والان نحن نرى ان اا ليس من الممكن اي
دوله بما في ذلك افيديان الساون او الولد
المتحده واي دول اخرى تبني مستقبل احسن
بدون مشاركه نصف سكان ولذلك نحن الولايات
المتحده ناخذ موقف قوي جدا دود هذه
القرارات واسماءنا من المجتمع دوري ليس
فقط من الغرب
والاوروبا لا سمعنا بشكل واضح من الدول في
هذه المنطقه في في اسيا وفي اماكن اخرى
همم
هذه القرارات شكرا لك لكنني لا زلت لا
اعلم كيف سيكون بامكان المجتمع الدولي ان
يضغط على طالبان وينقذ الفتيات من براثن
هذه المجموعه شكرا جزيلا لك همم
باسم الخارجيه الامريكيه شكرا
[موسيقى]
الى ملفي اوكرانيا قالت رئاسه الامريكي
الاوكرانيه ان روسيا لا تريد المفاوضات
وتتنصل من مسؤولياتها جاء ذلك ردا على
الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين الذي اكد ان
بلاده مستعده للتفاوض بشان حلول مقبوله مع
جميع اطراف الصراع في اوكرانيا لكنه اكد
انه مرافضوا ذلك وقال بوتن ان صراع في
اوكرانيا قائم بسبب الاطماع الجيو
السياسيه ورغبه الخصوم في تفكير روسيا
ينضم الينا ااا من موسكو عبد الجواد الرشد
مراسل العربيه اهلا بك نبدا بالسياسه في
الاول بوتن يكرر الدعوه للتفاوض ويلوم
الغرب اوكرانيا تقول انه غير جدي هل هو
جدي
انها المحاوله الاخيره هذا العام من
الجانب الروسي للعوده لطوله المفاوضات مع
الغرب ممكن طبعا تحدث اليوم عن جاهزيه
موسكو لجلوس طاوله الحوار مع الشركاء
الغربيين رغم طبعا حديثه عنهم بانهم غير
يعني جديين ولا يعملون على هذا المحور لكن
طبعا اذا ما تم قراءه ما بين سطور الرئيس
ابو تن حسب المحللين السياسيين في البلاد
فاننا نلاحظ بانهم يعني يوجه رساله صريحه
للغرب ما فاتها بانها بان الوقت حان
للعوده لطاوله المفاوضات خاصه ان المنطقه
في المنطقه الغربيه في في
مقدمه على عمليه كبيره من العيار الثقيل
والحل الوحيد لها هو الحوار المبدا للوقف
للوقوف على كافه التفاصيل طبعا الرئيس
بوتن في حديثه اليوم تحدث عن ثلاثه ملفات
رئيسيه الاولى هي العوده لطاوله المفاوضات
الثانيه هي طبعا قطع الطريق بما يخص انظمه
الدفاع الجوي الامريكيه التي تعتزم واشنطن
تزويده كيف بها وقلب ان موسكو ستستهدف
معظم هذه الانظمه وستكون طبعا محطه او
نقطه وصول بندقيتها اليها لكن الملف
الثالث والاخير بان تموت تحدث عن ان موسكو
ذاهبه في العمليه العسكريه الروسيه الخاصه
في الاراضي الاوكرانيه نحو تحقيق كافه
اهدافها وهي تبحث عن مصلحه مواطنيها وعن
وحمايتهم ومصلحته روسيا في تلك المناطق في
الجنوب الاوكراني وفي المناطق التي ضمتها
تصعيد عسكري ويعني تصعيد اللهجه يكون هناك
تفاوض واحيانا بعد فشل الوصول الى التفاوض
او فشل المفاوضات يكون هناك تصعيد عسكري
هل نحن مقبلون على مستجدات ميدانيه ضخمه
على الارض
ريما يعني اذا ما تم قراءه الملف السياسي
في البلاد وراي المجتمع الروسي والناس وما
يتم تداوله على مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي
نلاحظ بان الجميع يتحدث عن ذهاب الامور
الى ابعد من ذلك التصعيد العسكري مقدم حسب
معظم القراءات السياسيه الامل في جلوس
طاوله الحوار هو بعيد نوعا ما خاصه يعني
بعد تزويد واشنطن والغرب العديد من
الاسلحه وزاره الدفاع الروسيه اليوم تحدثت
عن تدمير معدات مصدرها بولنديا القوات
الاوكرانيه لذلك ملاحظ بان الطرق كما يرى
المحللون السياسيون والعسكريون في البلاد
اصبحت مسدوده نوعا واخرها كان حديث الرئيس
شكرا لك
اما ميدانيه وفي اخر التطورات المتعلقه
بالعمليات العسكريه والحرب الدائره التي
تنفذها روسيا على الاراضي الاوكرانيه قال
احد الضباط في قوات لوغانسك المواليه
لروسيا بان القوات الاوكرانيه حشدت اعدادا
كبيره من الجنود والاليات العسكريه حول
مدينه
صفاقسفاو واشتد القتال بالقرب من فديه وهي
بلده تقع على خط المواجهه في شرق اوكرانيا
حيث تحاول قوته الروسيه تطبيقها كما قام
الجيش الروسي بتنفي هجوم على بدله رزودولف
في مقاطعه دوناتس خلال الساعات الاخيره
اعلنت سلطات وزابريجيا الموليه لروسيا
انشاء خط دفاعيه عميق ومحصل لابشال اي
تقدم منه الاوكراني وقالت في بيان لها ان
بناء الهياكل الدفاعيه على طول الخط
الامامي في زا بوريجيا على شكل انتهاء هذا
وتواصل القوات الاوكرانيه قصف مواقع
وتمركزات القوات الروسيه بالمدفعيه
ويتبادل الطرفان الاتهامات بتهديد سلامه
المنشئه النوويه هناك
[موسيقى]
في اوكرانيا ايضا على الرغم من الانقطاع
المتكرر للتيار الكهربائي في معظم انحاء
البلاد الا ان اجواء اعياد الميلاد كانت
موجوده في العديد من المدن التي اضاءت
سماءها انوار تلك الاعياد عندما يكون هناك
ما يكفي من الكهرباء لتشغيلها هذا ولي اول
مره يحتفل عدد كبير من الاوكرانيين بعيد
الميلاد عفوا في الخامس والعشرين من
ديسمبر اي تقويم الغربي عوضا عن السابع من
يناير القادم وهو التاريخ المحدد عاده
لاحتفال لدى الاوكرانيين وكذلك الروس
[موسيقى]
صبوره
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
قالت شركه روسيه انها ستشحن نحو 42 مليون
متر مكعب من الغاز الى اوروبا عبر
اوكرانيا وهو ما يتمشى مع معدل ما ااا مع
معدل تدفق الامدادات في الايام القليله
الماضيه خطوه غاز بروم جاءت بعد تصريحات
نائب رئيس الوزراء الروسيه الكسندر نوفاك
الذي قال ان غاز بلاده رخيص ولا يزال
مطلوبا وان قرارا بشان مركز محتمل للغاز
في تركيا سيتخذ في 2023
وفي نشره المساء ولكن بعد قليل
الجيش الليبي يحذر عبر العربيه من الوضع
السياسي الراحل في البلاد
[موسيقى]
احييكم من جديد مئه يوم بالضبط على
انطلاقه الاحتجاجات في ايران ومئه يوم على
وفاه مها سالمين تلك الفتاه الكرديه التي
اشعلت تلك الاحتجاجات ومن ثم اضرابات
اغضبت النظام الايراني ودفعت به لقمع
المتظاهرين من اعتقالات وقتل وقنص وصولا
لي فرملات الاعدام اخرها بحق الطبيب
الايراني حميد اغاني حسن له الذي يواجه
حكما بالاعدام بزعم مشاركته وزوجته في ضرب
عضو في البسيج المصير ذاته قد يواجه
المدونه الايرانيه بالتحقان نسيمي التي
اعتقلت بتهمته الافساد في الارض فيما عبر
ذوها عن مخاوفهم من اعدامها
[موسيقى]
سيدنا رسول
الاجهزه التابعه لنظام الايراني كل الجهود
وبشتى الطرق للوصول الى المحتاجين وقدت
المظاهرات واعتقالهم مخابرات الشرطه
الايرانيه اعلنت انها اعتقلت اربعه من من
وصفتهم باقاده الاحتجاجات في العاصمه
طهران متهمه اياهم بتعميم الفوضى والتحريض
على شغب
وبحسب الارقام الحقيقيه فان اكثر من
18,500 متظاهر تم اعتقالهم واكثر من 500
متظاهر قتلوا بينهم 69 قاصرا بدورها طلبت
الرابطه الدوليه للاكاديميين الايرانيين
في خطاب المفتوح موجه الى رؤساء الجامعات
بتحديد مرتكبي جرائم قتل الطلاب ومتابعه
اوضاع الطلاب المعتقلين
وقد ورد في البيان ان اكثر من 650 طالبا
اختطفوا على يد قوات الامن والاستخبارات
خلال ال 100 يوم الماضيه وكذا التقرير ان
عناصر الشرطه والامن الايراني طوقوا مرارا
حرام الجامعات بايران وحاصلوا الطلاب
وقاموا احيانا باطلاق النار عليهم
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
جاموسه الرزيق على راسي
[موسيقى]
في وقت ترك سكان العالم الكمامات وعدو
لممارسه حياتهم بصفه عاديه بيت الوضع
مختلفا تماما في الصين التي يبدو انها
ستعود للمربع الاول بتسجيلها معدلات
قياسيه في اصابتي كورونا بعد اسابيع فقط
من تخلي بكين عن سياساتها صارمه لاحتواء
الوباء ملاحظات مسربه من مسؤوليه الصحه
الصينيين تكشف عن بلوغ عتبه المليون اصابه
يوميا في مقاطعه
وحدها كما ان مستشفيات بكين تعجه بالمرضى
وما يقرب من 250 مليون شخص في الصين
اصيبوا بفيروس كورونا خلال ال 20 يوما
الاولى من شهر ديسمبر اي ما يعادل 18% من
السكان وفقا لتقديري تقديرا داخليا من
كبار مسؤوليه الصحه في البلاد وهو ما دفع
سلطات البلاد لوقف نشر اعداد الاصابات
اليوميه بفايرس كورونا من قبل لجنه الصحه
الوطنيه اثر تفجر الاصابات في سابقه هي
الاولى من نوعها اما في المدن الساحليه
وتحديدا مدينه سندجاو الواقعه شرقي البلاد
فهي تشهد بين
490.000
1530,000 اصابه جديده بكرونا يوميا
بارتفاعا يقدر بنحو 10%
وتوقعات حكومه مقاطعه
شرق البلاد ان يصاب ثمانون في المئه من
سكانها اين نحو 36 مليون شخص بالفايروس
حتى مارس المقبل واضافت ان اكثر من ثمانيه
عشره الف مصاب بكافد تم ادخالهم الى
المستشفيات الكبرى
اربعه اربعه سوق هذا الاسبوع افضل بكثير
من الاسبوع الماضي لقد بلغ ذروته في
الثانيه عشر من الشهر الجاري عند مصطفى
حوالي 240 الى 350 شخصا خارج المستشفى
لتلقي العلاج والان العدد يتراوح بين 240
و250 كان الناس ينتظرون حوالي ثلاثا الى
اربع ساعات الان يستغرق الامر حوالي نصف
ساعه
عكس بقيه العالم لا حديث في الصين الا عن
فيروس كمامات وفحوص المستشفيات تعج
بالمرضى والسلطات تحاول فرض رقابه على ما
ينشر عن الموضوع صور تذكر بايام بدايه
الجائحه
تقارير تتحدث عن 250 مليون اصابه في مختلف
في مناطق البلاد خلال 20 يوما فقط ما
يعادل 18 في المئه من السكان وفقا لتقدير
داخلي من كبار الصحه على سبيل المثال
تواجه المقاطعه الصناعيه في الصين اصابات
مرتفعه وصلت الى المليون يوميا ومن
المتوقع ان تتضاعفه وفق حكومه المقاطعه
اعتقد ان الوضع في المستشفى جيد بشكل عام
من رائع ان نرى قسم الطوارئ يعمل على هذا
النحو من جهتها توقعت حكومه مقاطعه في
منشور على وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي ان
يصاب 80% من اي ما يمثل نحو 36 مليون شخص
بالفيروس حتى مارس
الاحصاءات على صعيد البلاد غير مكتمله بعد
ما توقفت لجنه الصحه الوطنيه عن الابلاغ
عن اعداد الاصابات مما يجعل من الصعب تتبع
الحالات مجموعه عالميه تعمل على تتبع
انتشار فيروس كورونا قالت ان تفشل وباء في
الصين ياتي بسبب سلالات الفيروس التي
انتشرت في انحاء العالم مع عدم وجود
علامات حتى الان على ظهور متحولات جديده
خطيره
بلال الوجداني العربيه
[موسيقى]
قال مدير اداره التوجيه المعنوي في القوات
المسلحه الليبيه لواء خالد المحجوب في
لقاء مع العربيه قال ان الوضع الراهن في
البلاد لا يمكن السكوت عنه واشار الى ان
هناك سي ان عاما من الوضع
[موسيقى]
ان ما يحدث الان لا يمكن السكوت عنه هناك
تواصل مع كل المناطق في ليبيا تعلن عن
رفضها واستياءها باستمرار هذا الوضع وايضا
استعدادها للتعاون
والتعامل مع الموقف بما يقتضيه همم في ظل
ما تحدث عنه القائد العام بين القوات
المسلحه دائما للشعب وداعمه للحراك الوطني
[موسيقى]
في اليمن قال رئيس قسم الغسيل الكلوي في
مستشفى الثوره العام بتعز دكتور فهمي
الحناني في لقاء مع العربيه قال ان اكثر
من 260 مريضا بالمستشفى يحتاجون لغسيل
الكلى باستمرار وانا واقفه خدمات المستشفى
اثرا نافادى الديزل سيشكل خطرا عليهم
جدا طبعا لدينا في المركز اليوم اكثر من
88 مريض فشلوا الكلوي بحاجه الى الغسيل
ومن لدينا اكثر 260 مريض مسجلين في سجلتها
المركز يحتاجون الغسيل بشكل مستمر طبعا
توقف ماده الديزل على مرضى الفشل الكلوي
ليس للمره الاولى ولكن هذه اكثر من مره
بسبب عدم وجود ميزانيه كافيه لتشغيل همم
المستشفى بشكل عام لان ال- همم الميزانيه
المعتمده يا دوب 10 ملايين الريال التكلفه
التقديريه الشهريه تصل لا همم 60 مليون
فطبعا هذه المبالغ لن نستطيع همم توفيرها
مش اول مره
بالديزل وراقبك كرت الصباح يشتغسل هموم
مليان سواعد ما في جيزان
[موسيقى]
لما فوازير دفاع التركي خلاص الى امكانيه
عقد اللقاء يجمعه بنظريه الروسي والسوري
انه لا يجب تجاهل مثل هذه اللقاءات وان
بلاده ليست منغلقه والحوار مستمر بدورها
افادت وكاله الاناضول بتفقد وزير الدفاع
التركي وقادت الجيش واقع الوحدات العسكريه
المنتشره في ولايه هاتاي قرب الحدود مع
سوريا هذا وكان اكار قد قال ان تركيا تجري
محادثات مع روسيا لاستخدام المجال الجوي
في شمال سوريا في عمليه ضد الاكراد في
المنطقه
وفي نشره المساء ولكن بعد قليل
اضراب القطارات يفسد اهم ايام التسوق
سنويه في بريطانيا
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد عوده الشباكات القبليه
في ولايه جنوب دارفور بحياه 11 شخصا على
الاقل في المنطقه التاسعه المطربه الواقعه
غرب السودان وفق ما افاد مصدر طبي حيث دلع
اشتباكات لم تعرف اسبابها منذ ايام بين
قبائل عربيه من الرعاه واخرى افريقيه في
قريه قريبه من نياله عاصمه ولايه عاصمه
ولايه جنوب دارفور وفقا ما افاده شهود
عيان
[موسيقى]
رصد مراسل العربيه في باريس جوانب من
الاضرار في العاصمه الفرنسيه بعد مواجهات
بين متظاهرين اكراد والشرطه الفرنسيه على
خلفيات مقتل ثلاثه اشخاص من الجاليه
الكرديه في عمليه اطلاق نار
متناقضان للحياه الفارسيه صفوف طويله لمن
ينتظرون الدخول الى سيرك الشتاء التاريخي
لمشاهده عروض متنوعه وعلى بعد امطار سمحت
هدوء ما بعد العاصفه لسكان الحي والعابرين
فيه بمعاينه الاضرار سيارات قلبت او احرقت
وواجهات زجاجيه تحطمت جزئيه وغضب كردي
تفجر بعد ان اقدم يمني متطرف اقر بعنصريته
على قتل ثلاثه افراد وجرح ثلاثه اخرين
صباح الجمعه اقر المعتدي ايضا انه توجهها
صباح الجمعه الى ضاحيه سند حيث اراد قتله
اكبر عدد من المهاجرين لكن قله عدد الناس
في الشارع دفعته للعوده الى باريس حيث
اقدم على جريرته الثلاثيه حصيله المواجهات
واحد وثلاثون شرطيه جرح وجرح متظاهر ودعى
المسؤولون الاكراد الغاضبين الى الهدوء في
ما قال وزير العدل الفرنسي مطمئنا الاكراد
ان فرنسا كلها في عزاء وان دعمنا لكم ثابت
لا يتزعزع
[موسيقى]
تحرم اكثر من مليون منزل امريكي وكندي من
الكهرباء في ليله عيد الميلاد وتلغي مئات
الرحلات الجويه مخلفه اضطرابات كبيره في
حركه النقل العواصف الثلجيه والاجواء
المتجمده امتدت لاكثر من ثلاث ثلاثه الاف
ومئتين كم
من مقاطعه كباك في كندا وصولا الى تكساس
بالولايات المتحده الامريكيه العاصفه
الثلجيه المميته شلت الحياه في امريكا
وكان كندا لليوم الرابع على التوالي حيث
ذكرت السلطات بان اجهزه الطوارئ لم تعد
قادره على التعامل مع الظروف الصعبه
الناجمه عن الصقيع وارتفعت حصيله ضحايا
العاصفه الشتويه الشديده في جميع انحاء
الولايات المتحده الى 28 قتيلا مع استمرار
البرد القارس ورياح وثلوج خلال عيد
الميلاد وفق وسائل الاعلام الامريكيه كما
تسببت العاصفه الشتويه في اكثر من
رحله جويه في انحاء الولايات المتحده
وتاخر
6600 رحله اخرى بحسب موقع التعقب فلايت
[موسيقى]
كما ادى الجليد وثلوج الى اغلاق بعض
الطرقات في البلاد وهي الاكثر انشغالا بما
في ذلك طريق انترستيت سفنتي العابر
للولايات والتي اغلق اجزاء اغلقت اجزاء
منهم مؤقتا في كولورادونس وحذرت خدمه
الارصاد الجويه من احوال الطقس مميته وحدد
سكان المناطق المتاثره على التزام منازلهم
وافادت بان الرياح ادت الى انخفاض درجات
الحراره الى نحو 48 درجه مئويه تحت الصفر
في ولايه فلوريدا وتكساس انخفضت درجات
الحراره الى درجات التجمد وهي الدرجات
التي تقتل من يتهاون بها اذا ما بقي في
ظلها ممتاز وفق ما ذكرت صحيفه اما في كندا
فتحملت مقاطعه انثى وكباك اللعب الاكبر من
انفجار القطب الشمالي وشهادات معظم وانحاء
البلاد تحذيرات من البرد الق والعواصف
الشتويه
[موسيقى]
ينضم الينا بالمطار
مراسل العربيه اهلا بك يا حسين
لنبحث اولا بموضوع السفر لانه تعطيل
مطارات في الولايات المتحده الامريكيه في
كريسماس في عيد الميلاد شيء مهم جدا هل ما
زالت هذه الازمه العاصفه لا زال تعطل حركه
السفر
تحيه لك ريما هي ما زالت في الحقيقه ولكن
طبعا معظم المطارات التي تتاثر بها كثيرا
هي المطارات الكبيره مثل مطارات اتلانتا
او مطار سان فرانسيسكو او مطار شيكاغو
وخاصه الرحلات التي تتجه نحو الولايات
الشماليه التي ضربتها العاصفه لاسيما
المحيطه او التي تضم منطقه البحيرات التي
تلقت ال- ال- القوه الكبرى من هذا
الانفجار الكبير القطبي الكبير الكبير
الذي وصلنا نحن هنا همم فرجينيا وفي
ميرندا ااه تاثيره في الحقيقه ولكن همم
اليوم كان هناك تحسن بالنسبه لاعاده
الجدوله الرحلات هناك الغاء وتاخير لبعض
الرحلات لدي بعض الارقام تاخير نحو ثلاثه
الاف 1650 رحله والغاء
1637 رحله بينما كان يوم الجمعه كان هناك
الغاء مقارنه همم ثلاثه همم الغاء ثلاث
الاف 480 رحله هنا في مطار رونالدو
للعاصمه
عشان طبعا من 500 رحله تم الغائها تاجيلها
يوم الجمعه يوم الذروه الذي يسبق ليله عيد
الميلاد المجيد الان نتحدث عن بعض الرحلات
التي ايضا الغيت بالنسبه
للرحلات المتوجهه نحو الشمال لكن كانت
المفارقه ان ااه سالنا احد همم العاملين
هنا واحد المسؤولين قال لنا هناك رحله تم
الغاءها تتجه نحو الجنوب نحو فلوريدات هذا
امر غريب لانه فلوريدا صحيح فيها موجه برد
قارس ولكن لا يوجد عصير ولا همم ثلوج همم
كما ذكرنا تفضل
يعني المشهد من خلفك هو في مطار رونلد
ريجن لا اعتقد ان المشهد سيتئثر كثير لانه
حركه السفر ب25 يوم عيد الميلاد عاده لا
تكون بزخامه 24 و23 اذا ممكن للكاميرا ان
تسلط الضوء من خوله من حولك يعني او من
خلفك
ساتحرك بالكاميرا كما قلت ريما اليوم لم
يكن هناك ضغط كبير لان كما قلنا همم معظم
الضغط كان في يومين الثالث والعشرين
والرابع والعشرين من هذه السمره ليله عيد
الميلاد تحديدا حيث كانت العاصفه قويه جدا
همم
[موسيقى]
ويحاول ان يساعدني
توجه قليلا الى الامام
طيب فيما انت تتحدث ونرى مشاهد المسافرين
يوم عيد الميلاد عاده لا تكون كبيره ولكن
هناك الغاءات الفتني حسين انه اتصلت ببعض
الاصدقاء من ميامي من بعض الوقت حتى ميامي
لاعاده تقسم دبي مثلا في برد ولابسين
كنزات همم اخبرني عن الولايات التي تاثرت
بالفعل يعني نستطيع ان نقول ريما الولايات
التي نجت من هذا الانفجار القطبي من
الثلوج تاثرت برياحها العاتيه في الحقيقه
يعني ان يتم توجيه تحضيرات الى سكان
فلوريدا المعروفه بانها ولايه دافئه هذا
امر غريب ومستغرب همم بسبب هذه البروده
القارصه ايضا ادت الى ضغط كبير على شبكات
الكهرباء ومحطات تبيض الكهرباء بسبب همم
استخدام المواطنين في هذه الولايات غير
المعتدين في الحقيقه على هذه الموجه
البارده همم ادوات التدفئه والتسخير ما
ادى الى وجود ضغط على محطات التوليد
الكهرباء وايضا انقطاع الكهرباء عن عدد
كبير من الناس همم الان في هنا في
الولايات المتحده يوجد بحسب احصاءات رسميه
175,000 منزل يعانون من انقطاع الكهرباء
طبعا كان العدد اكبر يوم الجمعه حيث كان
هناك مليون و500,000 منزل عامه من انقطاع
الكهرباء
قلنا العاصفه هدات اا قليلا همم بتاثيرها
هذا قليلا البارحه كانت درجات الحراره هنا
في همم شمال فيرجينيا وفي ميرلاند نحو 16
تحت الصفر اليوم نحن نتحدث عن اثنين تحت
الصفر كما قلت انا الان في هنا في المطار
الحركه اليوم شبه عاديه هناك تاخيرات و
تاجيل ولكن حسب ما قيل لنا هذا التاجيل
تاجيل طبيعي بعضها خاصه الرحلات المتوجهه
نحو الشمال هي تم تاجيله همم بسبب العاصفه
التي تضرب همم ولايه شمال ولا سينما منطقه
همم غرب همم
ولايه غرب همم نيويورك وتحديدا مطري الجون
افنديا في هذه الولايه
همم هناك كل شيء مغلق الثلوج تغطي همم
المدرج ولكن بشكل عام في الولايات الباقيه
هناك برد ولكن الرحلات عادت كما كانت
المسافرين العرب
يذهبون الى نيويورك في ليله راس السنه
شكرا لك من مطار رونالدو حسين الطود مراسل
العربيه
تسببت توقف حركه السكك الحديديه في كندا
بحدوث فوضى للراغبين بالسفر لقضاء عطله
اعياد الميلاد وراس السنه ما دفع سكان
البحث عن طرق بديله للسفر
[موسيقى]
الى بريطانيا حيث يتوقع يؤدي الاضراب
الحاصل في البلاد الى افساد يوم بوكسنج دي
وهو اليوم الاهم للتسوق والاكثر نشاطا
بالنسبه للاسواق وهو ما قد يكبدوا تجاره
التجزئه خسائر بملايين الجنيهات
الاسترلينيه ياتي ذلك في وقت اعلنت
النقابه الوطنيه لعمال سكك الحديد ان
اضرابها سيستمر يوم السابع والعشرين من
ديسمبر الحالي
احتجاجا على الاجور كما ويستمر اضراب حراس
الحدود وضباط الهجره في عدد من المطارات
حتى الثلاثاء القادم لما ادى الى تاجيل
بعض الرحلات وخلل في الجدول الجدول
المواعيد
نبقى في بريطانيا اذ كشف استطلاع ان نصف
البريطانيين لن يتبادلو هدايا اعياد
الميلاد هذا العام في محاوله لتوفير المال
بسبب ازمه تكلفه المعيشه ومن من يننون
تقديم الهدايا الهدايا العيد فان نفقاتهم
ستكون محدوده لافراد الاسره وخاصه الاطفال
فتره عيدي الميلاد وراس السنه هي الاكثر
تكلفه بالنسبه للكثيرين وهؤلاء المتبدعون
يفكرون في انفاقهم وكيفيه التعامل مع
مواردهم الماليه بمسؤوليه في ضم غلاء
المعيشه المرتفع عند شراء الهدايا
همم موكا كافه
هذا العام واخترت المجيء الى المتاجر
لانها اكثر حيويه بدلا من التسوق عبر
الانترنت
لشراء الهدايا لتخليص مصروفاتي من مظاهر
الاحتفالي بعيد الميلاد وراس السنه تزيينه
وجهات المنازل بالاضواء المبهره بحسب
الامكانيات الفنيه والماديه خصوصا مع غلاء
المعيشه وارتفاع اسعار الطاقه
في هذا الشرعي اعتدى سكانه المنافسه
لاظهار افضل زينه الاضواء هذا العام و
بسبب اسعار الطاقه المكلفه تجنبت اسر زينه
الاضواء فيما اخرون وصلوا على التقليدهم
باستخدام مصابيح اقل استهلاكا للكهرباء
لجمع التبرعات
تكلفه تزيين منازلنا في هذا الشارع هذا
العام وهناك من لم يزين منزله ولكن هذه
تقاليد عيد الميلاد
الاضواء الرائعه هذه تجذب الزوار من مناطق
عده
»
لمواجهه التكلفه المعيشه اضافه الى اسعار
الطاقه دفعت بلديات وجمعيات التجار باضاءه
اضواء عيد الميلاد ثمان ساعات بدلا من 24
ساعه لتوفير استهلاك الكهرباء هذه الاضواء
كانت تستقطب المتسوقين كعادتها لكن
انفاقهم هو اقل بكثير من الاعوام الماضيه
مصطفى زارو العربيه لندن
من لندن يبقى معي مصطفى ازارو مراسل
العربيه يعطيك العافيه تحت المطر انت
وفريق العمل
مصطفى
حرس الحدود بالاول لانه هيسروا مهم جدا
للمسافرين وكاتبك العرب اييه هل اوقفوا
الاضراب او مستمر راينا مشاهد للجيش يستلم
الحدود
لاربعه ايام فينتهي هذا الاضراب صباح همم
الثلاثاء المقبل ولكن هناك جوله ثانيه من
من الاضرابات تمتد لاربعه ايام اخرى ربما
ستكون الاسود بحسب بعض التحميلات ولكن
المطالب هؤلاء همم المدربين عن العمل
من المسافرين وهمم ومن يريدون المجيء الى
هذا البلد يختارون هذه الفتره همم من
السنه ولكن يبدو ان هؤلاء المسافرين
استمعوا واخذوا بنصيحه المسؤولين سواء من
قبل هذه المطارات السته التي اعلن فيها
هذه الاضرابات
بالاضافه الى همم جنوب البلاد لكن الحكومه
مصره على انها ستق فقط طيب رفع اجور
بالنسبه لا تتعدى ال 5% وهناك ربما
امكانيه ان تمتد هذه الاضرابات لتشمل
مطارات ومواني اكثر مما سيشل البلاد اكثر
مما هي عليه الان مصطفى بكره بوكسنج داي
وبلشت التنزيلات والسيلز يعني بيتروا كثير
هذا اليوم ل- اا تجار همم والمحطه محطه
القطار من خلفك شبه مقفله ماذا نتوقع غدا
ااااه القطار عمال سكك الحديديه سيستمرون
في اضرابهم حتى صباح الثلاثاء المقبل
وهناك ايضا خمسه ايام اخرى ابتداء من
الثالث من يناير الى غايه السابع منه اييه
هذه الاضرابات حتى هذه اللحظه في هذه
الفتره الحساسه جدا ستكلف الاقتصاد
البريطاني مليار و500 مليون اذا ما اخذنا
بها الاعتبار المصاريف هؤلاء الذين يريدون
ان ان نستمتعوا بهذه الفتره المقاهي في
المطاعم يعني قطاع الضيافه هو اكبر
المتضررين بالاضافه الى قطاع السكك الحديد
وبالتالي همم يعني همم المشاكل ربا ستزيد
ولكن هذه المصاريف التي يمكن ان تصرف في
المتاجر ربما لن يتم صرفها وبالطبع يعني
المصروفات والانفاق العام يعني كما لاحظنا
بانه هو اقل بكثير مما يعني ان ربما دخل
هذه سيكون اقل بكثير من السنه الماضيه
في راس السنه الى بريطانيا كيف تنقل اذا
مش عبر القطارات هل في زحمه بالطرقات بسبب
التعطيل
همم هناك الحافلات وهناك ايضا بعض
القطارات المحدوده التي تربط بعض نواحي
المنطقه التي يتواجد فيها الشخص وبالتالي
هناك يمكن اعتماد على همم استخدام السياره
او حتى سيارته اجره ولكن بشكل عام ربما
ستكون هذه الفتره هي اهدى فتره سنشهدها
منذ سنوات يعني قليله الماضيه يعطيك الف
عافيه مصطفى زارو ومراسل العربي
[موسيقى]
نشرت صحيفه ماركا رياضيه مقطع فيديو يظهر
عائله الاسطوره البرازيليه بيليه الى جانب
الى جانبه وهو يرقد الى او على سرير
المستشفى بسبب معاناته مع مرض السرطان
دقيقه
[موسيقى]
هذه وقفه مع ابرز احداث يونيو هذا العام
[تصفيق]
اجدمات
شو رايك
[موسيقى]
كان بقاء الكتله الصدريه
عائقا امام تشكيل الحكومه
وكل نواب الكتله زادهم الله شرفا
مستعدون للاستقاله
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
اسمه بلاي ستيشن
[موسيقى]
وهذا ما جاء في اخبار المساء
وكبريات ومنظمات الاغاثه تعلق عملها في
افغانستان
ترد دعوات غير جديه
مسؤلونا صحيونا يقرون بملايين اصابات
كرونه بالبلاد وبكين تقرر وقفه نشر بيانات
انتشار الفيروس
العواصف
ثلجيه القاسيه تواصل ضربه مناطق امريكيه
ضحايا وقطع للكهرباء والتوقف الرحلات
الجويه
على نشره العربيه
360 مساء الخير طاهر ريما شكرا
نحن سيكون لدينا متابعه ايضا لموضوع حظر
التعليم وكذلك توظيف للفتيات والنساء في
المنظمات الحكوميه معنا شبنا الجميله
الصحفيه الافغانيه تعطينا المزيد من
التفاصيل عن هذا الموضوع
[موسيقى]